what was your lowest moment as an actor
there was a point where I was kind of I
went to an audition and a family
degrading oh man it was it was pretty
bad because it hit every stereotype that
the other folks think of you and they
were trying to make me doing this and a
lot if it was one of those improv or
something funny I get it but it was kind
of one of those things that's how they
saw how they portrayed me in it it was
that wasn't like the one and only time I
was kind of like I can't this is
unbelievable I can't do it then you talk
to some people and you realize why you
really out hit and you get over it but
it was just that I remember that one
moment I was just like wow I can't do
this I did walk out you know the project
was whatever it was just yeah it was
tough but that was my only moment really
it happened once you left the audition
oh yeah you just said that much I just I
had to go cuz I was not in the I wasn't
even trying it was just kind of like wow
you really wanted to do this for me to
say what how do you want my clothes to
be quiet woody what is this role and
then yeah I kind of just left shouldn't
do that but that wasn't like a project
it was mainly something low-budget yeah
but lesson learned I talked to a few
people and he said you know I should
have handled it a little
we've heard from some people who've made
it in the business that there was one
time when somebody higher up on the
industry food chain said to them you're
not gonna make it in the sound has that
ever happened to you or someone that
you've known and how did either you
handle it are they I haven't heard you
won't make it in town but I've heard you
can never be that leading role kind of
guy with your how do I say this I've
heard it once I have heard it once from
an agent and that agent is funny because
that agent doesn't really have a Rolodex
of actors
he just had like a couple and it was
funny to me because now because I
remember a friend of mine went to an
audition and he told me that that guy
was there haha that's funny trying to
squeeze his actor in but yeah I heard it
once but I laughed it away because I was
just like haha that's funny yeah I don't
care what you say because you know you
don't make things happen I do so why do
you think someone would say that to
someone are they trying to squash them
are they maybe they wanted to be an
actor themselves and they wound up that
may have a lot to do it but I know that
he had another actor one of his clients
was probably the summer to me just a
black guy or this and that and he was
kind of like down greeting me to find a
way to push his actor and so I mean I
understood what he was doing it's just
you know it's just funny to me cuz I
don't care what another person says
because you're an agent you're just an
agent you're not making any real
decisions of who's gonna be in this
movie or now so I dusted off for the
matter and the same with other rejection
yeah you get a rejection who cares
there's gonna be plenty more trust me
especially when you make some small name
for yourself you're gonna get it's gonna
keep on happening
you